welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
and this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
miles morales game
spider-man 2 is obviously wall crawling
its way onto the playstation 5 at some
point
and this entry does an excellent job of
teasing to us what could be happening in
it
now in order to fully discuss what the
overall arc of the game is
we have to firstly go over its story and
discuss who the main players are
after the events of the first spider-man
game miles has really started to come
into his own
and thanks to the guidance that peter
provided him he pretty much
ends up switching places with him as the
city's spider-man
it isn't the only thing that's been
switched with peter as well god damn
now the game opens with the pair taking
down the rhino after a botched convoy to
the raft unleashes him in the city
this mission also introduces us to miles
bioelectricity venom powers
and the roxon corporation who become
integral to the entry
peter travels overseas with mj to be her
photographer
and miles has to keep an eye out on the
events that are going on in manhattan
throughout the game we discover that
roxanne's head of r d simon krieger
is in possession of an experimental new
piece of technology
known as new form if you're familiar
with the comics then you'll know that
this was actually a form of vibranium
that was developed by the corporation
new form pretty much becomes the
mcguffin of the entry and what the main
plot revolves around
and what the ending of the game becomes
tied to now on one side is roxon
and on the other is the tinkerer who we
discover is miles's close friend finn
finn is the leader of a group known as
the underground and
after setting up base inside kingpin's
tower they've started to carry out
attacks
everything ties back to her brother
namely rick mason
who we discover was a scientist that
worked at the corporation
after he learned that new film was
poisoning people he decided that he had
to sabotage the company
and together with finn they set out to
destroy the corporation's core
rick was killed during this and thus
finn has made it her mission to put an
end to new form and the company's
experiments now you may also know that
rick mason is a character
known as the agent and he will be
appearing in the upcoming marvel movie
black widow
if it ever gets released whilst it does
seem like he died during the course
explosion you can never say never when
it comes to the marvel universe
and we'll discuss this in more detail
later miles gets caught up in the middle
of it
and he also has to contend with the fact
that his uncle aaron is revealed to be
the prowler
if you've seen into the spider-verse
you'll instantly be up to speed with it
but this game does a great job of
developing their relationship beyond
what we saw in that film
it's revealed that aaron has been in
league with roxanne the entire time
and he betrays miles after learning
where the character plans to meet finn
aaron tells them not to harm miles
however the corporation goes against
this
krieger interrogates miles and then has
his forces beat the crap out of him
miles manages to escape with finn after
unleashing a massive venom blast
and aaron pretty much gets given an
ultimatum by krieger
krieger tells him that they can do what
they want with miles
and if he goes to the police that he
will then go to jail along with them
finn also decides that miles is too much
of a bad thing
and she beats him up badly and heads out
to fulfill her mission
it all comes to a head when finn returns
to roxon in order to overload the core
it's revealed that krieger actually
changed the specs of the machine
and if it detonates the core will
destroy the entirety of harlem
along with itself miles and finn go
head-to-head
and the former eventually manages to
convince the latter that destroying it
will cost countless lives
it's too late though and the core goes
critical which forces the pair to
enact a plan to save the city miles
absorbs the energy from the core
and finn realizes that this is history
repeating itself
and that miles could end up sharing the
same fate as her brother
thus she uses her tinkerer gadgets to
propel them both into the sky
far away from where it can do any damage
however because miles can't hold the
energy in much longer
he must detonate while she holds him
there and unfortunately it appears that
she dies
as he unleashes the blast i'm not 100
convinced that finn died during this and
i do believe that both she and her
brother will be back at some point
as we know both are big characters that
are integral to the marvel universe
and we never actually see the pair's
bodies both finn and rick disappear as
the core explodes
and though they aren't anywhere to be
seen that doesn't mean that they're gone
i really like the relationship that was
built up throughout the game with miles
and finn
and i can see the latter returning at
some point in the future it is possible
that both are in an alternate dimension
and this could open the door for
characters like gwen stacy and
spider-man 2099
as for krieger the character is arrested
and then sent to jail
it is revealed that aaron actually went
to the police and though he was put in
prison as well
the villain is now facing a reduced
sentence because he handed over
information on krieger
thus it is possible aaron 2 could return
down the line
and it shows how far he's come from the
beginning early on in the game we
discovered that he ruined the
relationship he had with his family
because of his nighttime activities
but here it appears that he's willing to
do the right thing and thus we know that
he will be accepted back with them in
the future
miles's mother also gets elected as a
councilwoman and miles places a memorial
to his fallen friends at the trinity
church
though this does come slightly later the
game ends with miles walking past the
mural that we saw at the start of it
and though the artists had not painted
his face in it at the beginning
we can now see it up there with peters
showing that the city has two
embraced him as their savior miles meets
up with peter
and the pair swing off together as a
team and that ends the main story of the
spin-off
it's an awesome way to open and close
the entry but as this is marvel we also
have to deal with a big post credits
scene which teases what's to come
now if you're enjoying this video and
i'd absolutely love it if today was the
day that you decided to subscribe to the
channel
by hoping to hit the 400 000 mark by the
end of the year
and it would mean the world to us if you
did as a special thank you we're giving
away three copies of the marvel phase 2
box set on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th november
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part anyway you may remember that the
original game ended with us discovering
that harry osborne was in fact not away
on vacation
and that he was actually in a tank at
ozcorp we learned that harry had been
suffering from ashtaron syndrome
and that norman had placed a symbiotic
lifeform on him in order to cure him
we can see in the cutscene that this
black substance is bonded with the
character
and i don't feel like anyone should get
any prizes for guessing that this is in
fact
venom norman orders that his son is
released from the tank
and clearly this is setting up a lot of
things now the green that is laced
throughout the scene
is definitely a color of the green
goblin who of course is synonymous with
the osbornes
with harry pretty much confirmed as
venom i actually think that his father
will be the one taking up the mantle
if i was to make a prediction i would
say that i think harry being prematurely
set free
will cause him to transform into the
villain venom norman will try and stop
him from destroying the city
and thus he will don the green goblin
costume in order to bring him in
this will allow for both the villains to
be major antagonists in the next entry
and i love how we have this repetition
of peter's allies becoming the big bad
in the first spider-man game peter was
of course having to contend with the
fact that his men to doc ock
had turned to the dark side and once
more we will get this motif of
spider-man's enemies also being his
allies
this opens the doors for a lot of
complications with mary jane
and also enables characters like carnage
to be brought into the franchise
with miles at his side i really feel
like the game's creators can throw a lot
more at peter
a nurse i do think we will see far more
villains in the upcoming ps5 release
now there's also another very important
character in this scene
that you may have missed working on
harry is dr kurt connors
who fans of the franchise will know as
the lizard
i think these three characters being in
the same place at the same time for the
post-credits scene
also lets the audience know that these
will be the three main villains of the
next game
and connors could tie into the overall
storyline in a number of ways
if osborne is indeed trying to track
down his son it makes sense that he
would have connors getting involved
as he was a part of the experiments that
they were carrying out
this could lead to the lizard somewhat
becoming a henchman of the goblin
and we could watch his connors
attempting to help norman catch his son
leads to him transforming into a monster
i also found it interesting that this
post-credits scene was shown from the
perspective of harry himself
and he may even be a playable character
in the next game
if he is venom he will have similar
powers to peter and miles
and they can go this route without
changing too much of the gameplay
there are a wealth of possibilities they
can travel down
i'm just so happy that we have another
stellar entry in the spider-man universe
miles was a blast from start to finish
and what a way to kick start the next
generation of gaming
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the game and what you want to see in
a sequel
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the best fan theories on
who baby oda is
we go over the most likely ones from top
to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
can also come chapters on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you